[Musique]
pour moi les fleurs c'est ce qu'il ya de
plus beau c'est j'aime être entouré de
beautés et la nature 9 vraiment les
merveilles tous les jours
tous les matins il y la bête ait fait le
tour de son jardin pour cueillir des
fleurs
elle a rempli son panier de couleurs et
peu à peu de la peintre elle compose sa
palette
je vais cueillir un géranium vivace
d'uranium est très simple comme fleurs
mais il al'avantage de de sécher en
entier et puis de garder très bien sa
couleur
[Musique]
une fois la récolte terminée
commence alors un travail très minutieux
cette amoureuse des fleurs les reprend
une à une pour les faire sécher avec une
technique bien à elle elle pose les
fleurs entre deux voix deux chambres et
intercale une sorte de matelas qui va
absorber l'humidité
elle met ensuite sous presse au bout
d'une semaine
lafleur est prête pour une autre vie
quand vous faites un bouquet dans un
vase
malheureusement au bout du jour le les
fleurs sont fanées
donc moi je voulais donner une seconde
chance aux fleurs les pérenniser
et donc c'est en et ses chances ou
presque que l'on arrive à garder les
couleurs et pour pouvoir ensuite faire
autre chose avec les fleurs
au fil du temps elisabeth est passé
maître dans l'art de la flore pressée
elle métamorphose pas moins de soixante
mille fleurs chaque année les fleurs en
ses chances ou presque reste très souple
et je peux les manipuler à la main ne
sont pas fragile c'est comme du papier
de soie
c'est très fin le pavot d'islande et
magnifique peuvent pour la transparence
ça nous permet de faire des
superpositions et les couleurs se voit
par transparence des superpositions sont
magnifiques
pour cet artiste de la nature chaque
fleur chaque pétale est source
d'inspiration
c'est ainsi qu'elle crée paysage
patchwork ou mandala j'utilise plein de
variétés de fleurs suivant l'ordre
affichent leurs couleurs les fleurs en
salle d'étonnant c'est que chacune est
différente et on en met d'avoir beaucoup
de gratuité je m'étonne à chaque fois de
la variété de choix qu'elle m'offre dans
la création la créatrice fait imprimer
ses compositions sur du tissu
c'est en velours qu'elle décrit mme sacs
trousses pochette et qu'elle donne une
touche moderne à ce fauteuil